au pétard larrezet l'excitation est à
son comble pour ces agents du
département déguisés pour l'inauguration
de la prochaine exposition du muséum
d'histoire naturelle ce sont des
personnages qui ont fait le concret le
muséum d'histoire naturelle à son début
moi je suis augusto lance le premier
conservateur mais je suis pas encore en
tenue faut que j'y aille
après cinq mois de travaux et beaucoup
d'engagement
c'est le temps des restitutions c'est
dur la vie d'un conservateur de l'autre
côté les invités arrivent inébranlable
partenaires donateurs amis scientifiques
tous ceux qui font l'âme de ces lieux le
1er février 1854 et publié l'arrêté de
création du muséum d'histoire naturelle
c'est le premier musée de la rue
monsieur joseph dernier
botaniste et son épouse 25 pièces
l'exposition collection collectionneur
est une invitation au voyage
elle est en effet un voyage dans le
temps en fait une histoire qui commence
dix années après l'abolition de
l'esclavagé et avec une collection de
cinq cent mille pièces dont 100 milles
environ peut être exposée et avec un
relooking extraordinaire du musée
ce temps naturel ici dans les jardins de
l'état c'est vraiment quelque chose de
magnifique à venir voir une visite dans
un hall d'exposition totalement refait
où les univers s'enchaînent tout comme
les époques et pour sa conservatrice
c'est d'ailleurs cette dernière
exposition c'est de montrer que derrière
les collections qui sont le coeur même
d'un muséum d'histoire naturelle il même
d'un musée tout court il ya des hommes
c'est naturellement que les
collectionneurs
vers moi et du coup c'est voilà c'est ce
sont des relations de confiance derrière
elle des passionnés qui lui ont fait
confiance au fil des années d'imminent
collectionneurs qui apportent leur
pierre au savoir collectif
[Musique]
ça comprend vite la vie dans laquelle
dix ans et qui puissent les protéger
et puis à un moment si vacances ça sert
d'avoir des insectes dans une boîte et
puis je connaissais très bien sonia
ribes et jamais vu le sérieux de son
travail avec d'autres travaux programmés
dans l'avenir cette étape permettra au
muséum d'histoire naturelle de devenir
bientôt une référence de la biodiversité
dans cette partie du monde
[Musique]